and even cold omen nim shungi hyang savage s video disc
sting naro and as if there is no other way Sting Bike Winner In spring, as Buddha’s fur, Varus
overcame lfe waterside and hit par en silla
Shunsk mtm  Encoding Asti Snowball Fighting Plan Me
[Music]
Hello, I'm Kim Byung-jin of a Korean restaurant gown restaurant.
I've never thought of wanting to do 3 f for some reason
.  But now
I think I got arrested as I went to the assembly department.
I think it was from studying
Korean food. While thinking about what Korean food was, I came across a book called
Food Room.  It was a cookbook that depicts the interest in ordering while applying it to the menu I am currently working
on with a glass boat that focuses on expressing the taste of one ingredient without many things being mixed with the central point of some parts
.
My name is that person.  When the food is half recently, when you turn 13, the
grandmother wears the cooking water written about 350 years ago. The
first Jo Lees buck written in Korean in Korea
It is known as the first
cooking water written by a woman in East Asia.  Yes, I write it backwards at the time of writing it. This is a book that writes
down how I did not taste the clock just because I was just or salting it. On
the last page, I read this book number one.
Bulcheok has come.
So, descendants kept the word, and now the original is kept in the library of Kyungpook National University.
Because I believe that creativity is to focus on cultivation and find suitable things for
the material,  I tend to like it,
but I have a lot of obsession with it.
I think that everything we do is based on tradition and we know it, so I also think that the parts we do
are very important because we have customers who can become traditions at some point.
It
may be a part, but when there are many parts that someone can continue like the king of tweaks, I think that this
is the philosophy we will proceed because it becomes a place to make small elements as a culture that many people can enjoy.
I think
that reproducing and promoting Korean food saves Korean food, and that eventually globalizes
woo